hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
we're going to be solving a binary
question
counting bits and this is one of the
binary questions from the blind 75 list
that we've been tracking in the
spreadsheet so we will finally be adding
a
video solution to this binary problem
i'm pretty sure it used to be a medium
problem which is why it's highlighted
yellow but i think it got changed to an
easy problem
so the statement is pretty simple we're
given an integer n and we want to return
an answer array of length n plus one
basically a value for every integer in
the range from zero
all the way up until n so if n happened
to be
zero then we would just return a single
integer if
zero happened to be two then we would
return three integers for
zero one and two and basically for every
value
in this range zero to n so if n was two
we would have three values in that range
zero one two for each of these values we
want to know what
is the number of ones in the binary
representation
of this particular integer now what's
the binary representation of zero it's
of course just
zero right you could add multiple zeros
but it's
still going to be zero what's the binary
representation of one
it's going to be just one right you
could have some leading zeros we could
have as many as we want
but at the end it's just going to end
with a single one so there's only
one occurrence of the integer one in the
binary representation of 0.
so so far our output is going to look
something like 0
1 and then now we just need the number
of ones in the binary representation of
2.
the binary representation of 2 is going
to look like this 1
0. you could have some leading zeros but
this is the main part that we're looking
at so
it just has a single one so then the
output is going to be
one for that so the array that we would
return is going to look something like
this
zero one one now the brute force way to
solve this problem
is going to be n log n and that solution
is going to look something like this
let's say we had an arbitrary
value such as 2 or maybe even 3 right we
know the
binary representation of 3 is going to
look like 1
1 right so how are we going to count the
number of ones
in the binary representation of three
well we first let's get the ones place
right is this gonna
is this gonna be a one or a zero how can
we get that well we can take three
mod it by two which is gonna give us one
so we have at least
one one here right so we already looked
at this position so what we do is
basically cross it out and then we just
want to look at the remaining
portions now how can we actually do this
uh like what kind of operation can we do
basically if you take
three and divide it by 2 integer
division here
and most programming languages will do
this basically by integer division
what that's going to do to this integer
is it's basically going to take that
ones place and remove it
take the remaining bits and then shift
it to the right so it basically does
exactly what you would want to do
and of course what do we get when we
take 3 and divide it by 2
integer division is going to give us a 1
so we're basically going to get this
and when you look at that yes this is
the binary representation of 1
right so now we're gonna take this and
mod it by two as well we're taking one
modding it by two that's also gonna be a
one
so so far we've counted two different
ones for this integer
and again we're gonna take this uh
this one's place now and chop it off and
now we're left with a single zero so if
you take one
divided by two yes you get zero once we
get to zero that's how you know when
we're stopping
right there's obviously in zero there's
no more ones
in zero so basically we counted two
different ones
so that's how we would do it for every
particular integer the example i showed
right now is three
and to get this the time complexity is
log
n because for any integer n how many
times can you divide it by two well of
course
that's just log base two n now we don't
really worry too much about the base
usually but yes it's gonna be log n
log base two n that's how many times we
could divide any particular integer
n by two and of course we know we're
doing this for a bunch of integers in
the range
all the way from 0 to n so we're doing
this n times
doing a log n operation n times
is going to be time complexity and log n
now there's some repeated work
that we can eliminate that you can
easily recognize when you actually draw
out the bit mappings
the the binary representations of a
bunch of integers and with that repeated
work we can actually get a working o of
n
solution let me show you that right now
now i just drew out the binary
representations from zero all the way up
to eight so we know that of course
zero has zero ones in the binary
representation
when you get to one we have one
occurrence of one in its binary
representation for two we have
one for three by looking at this we can
see we have two different ones
and now when you get to four you really
start to notice how we are doing this
repeated work
notice how for four all the way to seven
we have a
one in this place right in the most
significant place
we have a one and notice how the
remaining portion
of this and then this and then
this and this these four
are just repeats of the previous four
that we calculated right because
we're you know we're counting zero zero
adding a one
right to four when you add a one you
just change it to this from four when we
add a two
we get this which is basically the
binary representation of two itself
right and then you get a one zero and
then you get a one
one which is matching over here so now
looking at it this is the binary
representation of
four right there's just a single one in
this position
so if we wanted to take zero and add
four to it we would just
to take this position and add a one here
right that will take us
four positions ahead and if you had a
one
and you and you changed this bit to a
one we're adding four to it so you can
take
a one and change it to a five by taking
that bit
so similarly when we get to four
we know that yes we're gonna have one
extra one
in this position right because we just
got this one this one represents a four
this is the most significant bit so far
but for the remaining ones all we have
to do
is take this offset it by four
and get here and count how many ones
were over here so when we're calculating
how many ones
for four we're just saying it's one plus
the number of bits at position
zero how many bits how many ones were in
position zero that's our dp so you can
see this is a dynamic programming
problem because we're using the previous
results that we calculated
to compute the new results in other
words this is going to be 1
plus dp of n minus
4 and actually when you look at this 5
we're also offsetting it by 4 to get
these two right because that's what's
going to match up with
this which is going to tell us how many
ones are going to go here right so and
clearly
we see that that's a 1. so here we're
going to compute
1 plus again dp of n
minus 4. and similarly for here we would
say
one which is coming from here plus the
number of ones
in this binary representation which we
know we already computed
up over here and the answer to that was
one so in this position
really there's going to be two ones in
this binary representation now over here
once again
we know that there's at least one from
here plus how many were in this binary
representation we computed that
at position three which again is offset
by four
so this is going to be one plus two
which is going to be 3.
now you get over here so now we have an
even more significant bit last time the
most significant
bit was in this position and we know
that represents the integer
4. now we got an even more significant
bit
which represents the integer a so
we know that this is going to have at
least one occurrence of one and then we
want to know how many
ones are in this binary representation
now
how are we going to get that in this
case you can tell
the the offset is no longer four because
if we do an offset of four we get to the
integer four that's not what we're
trying to do
this binary representation represents
the integer zero so in reality
we want to take eight offset it by 8
which is going to get us all the way
over here
and once you do that that's when you
actually notice the pattern since this
is going to be
1 plus dp of n minus
8 you can tell that for each value
this is going to be the equation 1 plus
dp of n minus a particular integer
and that integer is going to be called
the offset
and the offset is going to be the most
significant
bit that we have reached so far and what
are the most significant bits well the
first one is going to be a one
the next one is going to be a two the
next is going to be a 4 8
16. so basically they're doubling in
size every time because we know a bit is
just a
power of two right that's what binary
represents so let's clean this up just a
tiny bit
so we know that this is kind of our base
case zero is going to have zero ones in
it
now in the next position what's the most
significant bit we've reached so far
it's in the ones place right so
therefore it's going to be a 1. so when
we're computing
this we're going to compute 1 plus dp
of n n is always going to be the value
we're computing right now so that's
going to be a 1
minus 1 because 1 is the most
significant bit we've reached so far
down here we reached a new significant
bit of 2
right because we've gotten to the value
2 so far so
for here we're going to say 1 plus dp of
n minus
two now in this next position again the
most significant bit is
two right we we know that two is a
significant bit
the next significant bit is going to be
four because that's another power of two
so
three is not a it's still going to use
the previous value
so from here we're going to compute 1
plus again dp
of n minus 2. now once you get here
we see that we've reached a new power of
2.
so then we're gonna be modifying this to
one plus dp
of n minus four and then of course when
we got to
eight we know we reached a new power of
two so we were gonna do one plus dp of n
minus eight
how do you know if you reach a new power
of two well you can take the previous
power of two for example it was two
right
let's say the current power of two is
two let's say we multiply it
by two does that equal the current uh
value where if we got to three n equals
three
we would check does two times two equal
three no it does not so we did not reach
a new power of two
if we if we got to four two times four
that does equal
four so now we reached a new power of
two and then
from four we would do the same thing so
four multiplied by two
does that equal to seven right let's say
we got to seven and we were trying to
see
is this a power of two no this does not
equal seven but once we get to
eight then four times two yes that
equals eight right so we did reach a new
power of 2 and we'd do the exact same
thing
so the next time we would reach a new
power of 2 is would be 8 times 2
equals 16. so next time we reach a 16
that's going to be a new power of 2
and 16 times 2 is 32 etc etc so that's
how it's going to work
and once you know this idea it's not
super intuitive until you actually kind
of draw it out
but once you do the code is actually
pretty easy to write let me show you how
so our dp array is going to be
initialized to all zeros and it's going
to be length
n plus 1 because that's how many we're
trying to compute and we're also going
to have an answer
array which is initially just going to
have a single zero in it because we know
n is going to be at least zero and then
we're going to go through for i
in range all the way from one up until n
so n plus one this is non-inclusive in
python so we're actually going to be
stopping when we go from one all the way
up until n
and we're going to be keeping track of
one more variable the offset aka the
highest power of two so far so initially
that's gonna be
one so before we actually compute the dp
or the number of bits in this
integer i's binary representation first
we're going to check how
can we double our offset we're going to
check if
offset multiplied by two is equal
to i the current end that we have just
reached if it is then we can set
offset equal to i otherwise offset is
going to stay the same
and then we can actually compute the dp
so we're trying to compute dp of i
which is basically the number of bits
the number of ones in i's binary
representation we know that's going to
be at least
1 plus dp of i
minus the offset and actually one thing
i just realized
is the dp and the answer array are
actually the exact same i don't know why
i even created an answer array we can
get rid of that so this dp is basically
our answer array it's going to give us
the number of bits the number of one
bits in each integer's binary
representation so once
once we're done with that we can go
ahead and just return this dp array
so as you can see this is a pretty
efficient solution this is the linear
time big o of n
time and space solution i hope this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching